i mean i've had plenty of heartbreak in
my life
devastating heartbreak but what i'm
still trying to learn is
allowing for that that tenderness versus
going
versus going into fight mode go i go and
i go mikayla knows i go straight into
fight jadah pink and smith
gets real about love and heartbreak it
takes practice to have those difficult
conversations
on tuesday's episode of red table talk
the host sat down with her mom adrian
her daughter willow and and will smith's
personal relationship counselor michaela
baume where she admitted she has a fear
of being hurt
and i think that has a lot to do with
the fear of being hurt
yeah you don't want to feel rejected you
don't want to feel unloved right
being programmed and believing girl
don't let those tears come
yeah don't let those tears come because
you will fall apart
and you might not be able to put
yourself back together again but it
takes
a lot of just trusting yourself
you know and a lot of times we don't
have
enough self-worth and just like mom
willa opened up about her past
relationships and how she healed her
broken heart
you know i've had some personal
decisions i needed to make this year
that were really hard i had to just
learn how to set some boundaries
in my romantic relationship slash ships
while the 20 year old is private about
her love life willow has been
recently linked to musician tyler cole
i'm so grateful
that my partner was just open to what i
had to say
and when you truly love someone no
matter what you're going to want what's
best for them right
i felt like i was almost making the
situation bigger than it needed to be
and you guys really did a good job
working it out
together right michaela helped yeah a
lot
it wasn't nearly as tough as you thought
because i was building it up to me but
you had such courage about it
and you were so clear that you wanted
the best for
both of you and that's really quite
extraordinary
quite commendable if you look at willow
and how her her
life is going now and and the pattern
that she's creating for herself she i
think she's learned from you that she
has the freedom
to create what her life and pattern her
life the way she wants it
as for adrienne she opened up about a
different kind of heartbreak
this year it has really been the passing
of my mother-in-law
right right you know because yeah to
covet
it was very painful it was very very
painful
and then not being able to gather to
celebrate her life
the way we ordinarily would and when it
comes to love
gamey reveals there's one particular
marriage that was bound to fail
i really built up in my head that
this was my one true love and i'll never
love like this i'll never love like this
again yeah it wasn't a divorce
that i wanted but at the end of the day
when you
really really look at the relationship
honestly
you go it's like this one going nowhere
but to divorce yeah
[Music]
right